this is baby food mm-hmm
I'm gonna do that's baby food
[Music]
hi I'm Tanisha Olivette my name is Donna
Carol Crockett hello my name is Keyshawn
my name is Jonas came and I'm here to
taste these auntie's potato salad I'm a
little bit leery about tasting someone
else's potato salad that I don't know I
really don't eat everybody's potato
salad when I see a whole lot of chunks
going on potatoes that are half done I'm
not gonna do that
I've never liked potato salad on my life
once I had to make it myself I realized
the tech salad ain't that bad
if I make it I get a lot of compliments
I get people one in seconds one and more
I definitely believe I'm gonna be number
one period point blank period mm-hmm
listen if you were any closer you can
hear the point from my onions and my
bell peppers and all that good stuff
[Music]
looks like mashed potatoes that you know
was decorate it a little bit too white
for me I like it yellow and I already
kind of have a fear that I'm about to
taste mayonnaise let's give a little bit
of egg in there cuz I want to be fair
yeah I want to be fair this one tasted
like sugar was added to it oh my god
what is this this is a perfect example
of looks can be deceiving
because it's sweet like I like it and
it's not man easy
look how creamy this is like where are
the chunks I use look I can just pick it
up and decorate a cake with it
I don't like soupy potato salad that's
the first thing I noticed that made me
nervous right off top maybe I could get
some of this egg with the peppery cone
top I'm sorry I can't
is there any water I would give this one
a forest for the flavor I did like the
flavor of it but I want potato salad not
mashed potatoes I'll give this one an 8
yeah you can see I'm still eating a 2
you get 2 points for effort I was being
nice I could have said zero but I'm a
reserved zero in case someone else's is
worse
[Music]
well well you know did this potato salad
really looks good it's got a couple oh I
guess that would probably beat onions in
there I smell a little bit of seasoning
salt in here mmm no I can't
this is this baby food mm-hmm I'm gonna
duck uh-huh uh-huh that's baby food a
bit too much seasoning though right salt
you have to let all the ingredients do
their thing by themselves but it's
pretty I'm definitely gonna go with a
two for effort but the potato salad with
seasoned salt I don't think is a good
fix so I would give it a three this is
like potato salad for him when somebody
get all their teeth taken out and
they're gonna be fitted for dentures I'm
gonna say fix they took the time out to
make sure that they chopped up
everything you know and all that the
presentation was good it's not that it
was nasty or anything like that it just
had too much salt in too much mini yeah
this one would kind of give me heartburn
[Music]
wow this is like really actual cut-up
pickles in here pretty big I love
pickles but I don't really expect it to
be in the potato cell at this huge it
has big huge pickles in it these pickles
are too big it's really kind of shaking
me up a little bit these are really big
pickle chunks so I'm just hoping that
they're sweet already a little nervous
cuz I see these humongous
chunk love something and I don't know
what
oh not feeling it
no simply because it tastes like a baked
potato the presentation of this is
different and I'm probably gonna give
this a one simply because the pickles
are huge because of the effort I'm gonna
I'm gonna give this one I give this one
a 6
I do just taste pickles eggs mustard
seasoning and that's it there's a little
bit more to it than that
I can honestly give this one a 7
if I had to smile and eat it graciously
at a family event not to hurt aunties
feelings I could probably pull that off
[Music]
it look like they just put everything in
and just was like potato salad oh no
honey I don't know if I could do this
one oh no because this is a trying
I'm definitely gonna try this but this
looks disgusting I'm a woman of my word
I keep my word but she helped me we're
gonna father God thou are in heaven I
pray over this potato salad Lord God
please don't let it make me sick in
Jesus name I pray it might sound funny
but I'm serious ok see this is why I
don't want to put all this extra stuff
and potato salad what's that a stem be a
little bit more careful ladies now if I
find a shell in here I'm gonna sue
somebody this is horrible I'm being
honest who would eat this
know if that's a zero I knew I was gonna
reserve the zero for somebody this is a
zero I would give that one a two I don't
taste sweetness and if it is sweet then
the onion is overpowering it again like
this one this one just has too much
going on in it for me I'm definitely
gonna give this one I haven't tasted the
best potato salad other than my own my
own
[Music]
I can't tell you that I told you so but
you know follow my lead and you will not
be mistaken follow this girl okay cuz I
will beat your feet your soul your heart
and I'll love on you I'll care for you
and you just wouldn't have no doubt when
you roll with me hello like I said I
already knew it okay thank you ladies
for not being haters
[Music]